[Music]
so we all know that an experience of
trauma can cause post-traumatic stress
disorder it can be an experience that
marks and fundamentally transforms the
character of a person it can make them
meet the world with fear so my question
is is the opposite also true can an
experience of such radiance of such
grace of such astonishment and beauty be
akin to a kind of inverse PTSD and can
be as fundamentally transformative to
the character structure of a person that
it now shifts their lenses of perception
to lenses that meet the world not with
fear but instead with curiosity we all
have these lenses of perception we see
with our lenses we see through the
lenses we don't see the lenses
themselves right this self construct
this lens of perception this ego is
something that we mistake for what we
are it's not a fixed unchanging thing in
fact it's an amalgamation of past
experiences right you become your
experiences your cells are a technology
that turns experience into biology so
essentially eventually you meet the
world through a prism of expectations
shaped by past trauma past experiences
until eventually that lens is clouding
your encounter with the world so much
it's akin to a kind of tunnel vision you
don't see the world as it is you see the
world as you are and what if that filter
on the world is not serving you
what if seeing the world as you are is a
dark lens what if you don't like
who you are can you change who you are
well it turns out that ego dissolving
experiences can make the possessor of a
lens of percept
become aware that he has a lens of
perception and dispose of that lens of
perception if that no longer serves them
we need encounters with the numinous
experiences that recontextualize the
self so that you identify not with the
small self but with the self with a
capital S you stop tuning into the
broadcast of the ego and you tune into
the broadcast of the whole and when you
find another place to plant your feet my
friends when you meet the world from a
different vantage point you see that you
no longer are tethered to that old
monkey suit and that old monkey mind and
it is through these moments of grace
that you remember what you forgot right
you fundamentally transform your self
system and perhaps now can meet the
world not with fear but instead with
curiosity you have been absolved
[Music]
yeah you have been absolved now the
world becomes wealth a playground